I learned about other dancers and companies kind of on my own...
...once I started to develop into a ballet dancer.
But New York and ABT just always seemed like the ultimate.
I was like a child and it's crazy to like, think back on that.
I had no idea what to do, I didn't know how to take care of myself...
...and be on my own and travel alone.
It was a lot.
I was really emotional like, overwhelmed and I was already such a nervous girl.
Misty and I were the two out of the studio company...
...who were sent to go with the main company to China.
So, right away, we clicked and we got along and we were rooming together...
...and we became the best of friends.
We were both really young and naive,...
...and we'd never been in a professional company before.
And the company was a bunch of adults that had lived life and were married...
...and had been in the company for years.
They wouldn't help us if we asked them for help with choreography,...
..or they would say things to us during class while we were doing things.
If we messed up a turn, they'd be like, "Oh, better luck next time."
When you're in your adolescence and you're dancing,...
...you don't get to experience what normal kids get to experience.
You don't date, you don't go to parties, you don't hang out.
As soon as school's over, you're going straight to practice and to dance class.